okay I think work live ish hold on let
me make sure yeah looks like we are live
guys welcome to another exciting one
I've got a really really happy that we
we were able to put this together on
such a short time frame if everybody can
hear me go ahead and hit one in the chat
if everyone can hear audio why don't you
say something real quick Evan thanks for
coming on by the way thank you guys it's
to be here and finally be able to
confront these accusations that have
been laid on in the past sure I mean
coffee is Eli here is the first person
with a face who stood up against it and
said something so I'm really happy to
hear and rest the concerns for once and
for all
okay hopefully I can add some value to
everybody's time while they're here hope
you guys get to learn something and
hopefully I can inspire you awesome so
yeah I want to start with just a very
basic thing and I feel like this is this
is not controversial this isn't meant
you know get your anything like that but
I think one thing that I look for when
I'm looking at entrepreneurs stuff like
that is credibility and honesty I think
that if you like if you I think you'd
agree if you lie you lose credibility
right yeah hundred percent it's a lot
about being a [ __ ] absolutely and so
I feel like that's a lot of the
conversation that we're about to have is
that there's two cut there's kind of a
tale of two Evans going on I think
there's one side which is like the stuff
you'll see on you know Forbes you know
all these like you know these press
sites where you're kind of the king of
coding apps you've been doing it since
you're young you're successful investor
that's very polished it's very whatever
then there's this other story coming out
from what you would classify as haters
right and that say that you know most of
this is funded by your father's money to
project an image of success without
being the real thing and so for me
deciding which of those to believe and I
think for my audience what we have to
look at is which of these two cases of
these two tales of the two Evans that we
see on the end
are more credible I think that's like a
good place to start so with that said
let's just kind of jump into some of the
allegations or accusations whatever you
want to call them so let's start with I
think the the biggest maybe meme that's
come out of this which is Steve Jobs
okay tell me the full story of Steve
Jobs he's your mentor uh well before we
get to the question I want to say I
agree with you you've got you pretty
smart you've got a good grasp of the
situation what's really happened out
there is you know there is there's a lot
of misinformation and nobody can control
it today we sit in a world where the
internet which has given me everything
Internet has made me what I am right I
built all my businesses mostly on the
internet but it is also a tool where you
can spread a lot of misinformation
through so which is that's what has
happens there's this boon and there's
things and yeah I think it would be
great to come to some conclusions and be
able to give some more clarity around
these questions that and his allegations
have come up starting with the Steve
Jobs topic easier meant your question
was is he a mentor right yeah and just
tell us the story with Steve Jobs ah
yeah so basically you tell you the story
with Steve Jobs will be good if I could
spend a couple minutes in the background
first I'll be your mentor or not let's
just answer that question with yes or no
I think I would like to say yes oh he
was okay I mean if you look at the
Internet is my mentor right it doesn't
you don't have to talk to somebody all
the time to consider them your mentor I
would like to believe that the Internet
has been my biggest mentor right I
learned a lot I learned a lot from a lot
of people I've never talked to but I've
seen their videos I learned from them
and I would consider them my mentor so
cuz I've learned from them but as far as
actually communicating with him and
talking to him that only one call only
one call happens there's only one call
there's only once he actually talked to
me but that does not mean I can't learn
from me but I can't be inspired by it
this so when you this seems like a
little bit I mean I want to be
respectful here we just started but it
seems like a little bit of a question
dodge no like if I said you know Jeff
Bezos is my mentor
obviously I'm implying that he's
mentoring me in the classical sense of
like he's watched he's guiding me he's
pushing me out your it wouldn't be seas
it's up to you did you spend a lot of
time learning from Jeff Bezos did you
spend time actually actually I would
never talk I'm but I would never say I
was mentored by Jeff Bezos because it
has a different connotation I was
inspired by Jeff Bezos
that's a word right no but if you take
his learnings and build something upon
what he was working on right and if you
spend a lot of time on something that he
was working on and you're basically in a
way continued building on what he has
built right so if you today learn from
Jeff Bezos if you go and learn from him
right and if you read his books and if
you follow what he is taught and then
you go build I don't know one of the
biggest doors on Amazon right a very
successful store on Amazon in a context
you could say that he has mentored you
you are what you are because you learned
from him and took what he is foundations
or what he did and build upon that okay
without him in there you wouldn't be
here today in your example okay I think
this gets to my first problem though
with some of the stuff that you've said
is that a lot of it is self-serving
marketing that makes it seem like you're
more successful than you I'm not gonna
I'm not going to allege that you're
you've never done anything whatever but
what I'm saying is is that you're
manipulating you're using just we can
get into the doctor thing later you have
dr. Evan Luther there you're not a
doctor you have an honorary Doctorate so
it's like you're sort of trying to
market yourself as something that
actually there's no backing for and then
when pressed on it it seems like you say
oh well it's just that I was inspired by
him which everybody's inspired by Steve
Jobs does that mean we're all mentored
by Steve Jobs not everyone is no but not
everybody is building on his not
everybody's building apps not everybody
spent all this all their childhood all
the days
building tons of apps not everybody
spent days reading what he was doing
what he was guiding not everybody spent
hours in a row working on something that
he was talking about right and I mean in
the PhD I don't know if you want to go
to that right away oh no no no no no not
yet I just I just want to be clear
because I think again credibility such
an important thing here I think I think
see it's a lot about opinions right it's
a different way to look at it I can see
it it's out right I had one call with
him I'm always honest with that I had
one call with him and that's it and if
somebody wants to consider that that's
not a mentorship that's fine that's how
you wanna look at it but but to me I
consider him my mentor and that allows
me to go further I would like to believe
that if that allows me to become a
better person I don't think there's any
harm of that here's the thing though I
mean you say that you're you were not
you say you're mentored by Steve Jobs
but I have a little trouble believing
that because on our call I think
yesterday you said you were not mentored
by Steve Jobs and that you never said
that I'll play that up I'll play that
clip real quick for the for the audience
here so I probably can't hear that but
you said on the call I never said I was
mentored by Steve Jobs I never said that
and you could you play the whole clip
can you play the whole clip what I said
before not for that I mean that's
it was a long callers like 16 minutes
let's just play let's just clear the
next 10 15 seconds what did I say after
that yeah sure I'll try to pull it up I
mean I have to I like clipped it out
because it's it's just specific but I
said on that call to you I always said I
did one call with him that's it and
that's what I'm saying right now always
did one call with him no no no no no I
agree you said that but you said I never
said I was mentored by Steve Jobs I
never said that and that's what I'm
saying he did not meant for me you again
that's that's the problem just said you
were mentored by him yes I'm telling you
what I meant when I say mentored I mean
I learned from him and I've inspired by
him I did one call with him and I've
always said that I okay you read
everything I said she
I told you I wonder the first hundred
guys to make absolute eyes I built my
first app when I was in 2010 right in
2010 today's 20/20
that's what ten years ago okay so and I
wasn't I spent every day pretty much a
former childhood building apps I've sent
you all of that I'm guilt about 30 apps
before I turn 17 when all that I were
researching but but for me
go ahead of me I'm learning from him and
that's mentorship but ok I'm learning
from that's mentorship for me if it was
some other individual there I probably
wouldn't have done this because I
wouldn't have been inspired that my
individual see again like that's the
point I didn't want this conversation to
go where you're picking up if I if I'm
missing and defining the word how you
want to use the word mentorship right
that's not no it's not about that it's
about it's about honesty and
transparency and I really want to get
into this first 100 people who who
created an app I think that's a really
important point that you you've said a
lot and unfortunately it's not true so
you posted your first app on October the
15th of October 2010 you sent me a
screenshot of it okay of your Facebook
post about it can I show that yeah
that's public okay so this is his his
claim that he created an app this is
from his Facebook in 2010 the problem
though is that the App Store was
released in July of 2008 so and it was
released with 500 apps on the App Store
so the first 500 apps were done in 2008
two years before you're claiming you
were I said no no so again again the
first app I published where it was all
by myself before that I sent shoes if
you want if you want I can go to my
background I sent you my stuff over on
my blog my story is when how I started
building apps I had a blog it was the
most read blog on Lincoln's blogging
platform pumps I sent you that stuff too
if you want to pull that up so people
could see that I was the number one
editor on postmasters have to do using
the first a hundred person notes let me
let me let me give you the context
how did that empower that okay let me
give you the context so my blog was the
first it was the number one read blog on
LinkedIn on punch this lingual acquired
490 million if you want to pull it up
that would be great then Apple announced
about coming up with the App Store and
on this was published one of my blogs
the first app that came out my blog was
in there and that's after that point I
decided to make my own apps and launch
my own apps but my blog was already in
the first hundred apps that were
published and then I spent a long time I
spent over a year learning how to build
that that's when I published my first
after another 15 in sorry in October 15
which you saw which was about Delhi
Metro which was a react that was
downloaded a lot of times and became the
number one app on the App Store in India
it became the most downloaded app this
is it this is just isn't true you didn't
say that your blog appeared into the
first hundred apps first of all the
first hundred apps never existed was the
first 500 apps the App Store dropped
with 500 apps on it so just that numbers
completely that numbers completely
everyone - we can't we can't talk over
each other so let me talk so it's the
first 500 apps okay and then if you're
if you just appeared in a blog your blog
appeared on some app I'm sure a lot of
things appeared on the first 500 apps or
100 apps whatever you want to say but
that's not what you said I'm gonna pull
up another clip from our call where you
say that you built your first app at 12
okay let me play that real quick for the
audience you said I can prove this app I
built when I was 12 years old all of
this is verified you can verify this
right now you're claiming you built it
when your first app when you're 15 first
iPhone app App Store app my love that's
what I'm saying my blogs web app was
already life two years before that my
blogs web my first smartphone app no
there's a yes I my first web app was
before my first iPhone app was published
later and your question about the top
500 miles in the top 100 apps
yes now there's millions of apps in the
App Store but there's one two three four
there's this always already so my apps
in the first hundred apps that were
there it did not all this apps or not
all found apps are not in the first
hundred that's what I'm saying I have ad
turned multiple apps which have been
number one on the App Store and I've
sent you proof of that no no no I'm not
denying that hold on here's you also
saying by the way you published your
first app like iPhone app when you were
30 when you're 13 you said you passing
app store on Apple's page you can see
things I published on the App Store when
I was 12 13 you're claiming to publish
an app when you're 13 I don't know how
you're trying to get around no mate okay
it's in front of you everything is in
front of you in black and white you have
seen it okay you've seen it I've tell
you've seen the apps which are in front
of you which I've done when I was 15 I'm
saying it very clearly before that was a
blog I published and the blog was not
just any blog it's not just any
millionaire was a blog is the number one
no it's the blog the blog inside the app
was the highest level blog is the top I
showed you sent you the proof so my blog
was the one that made the app where it
is why it was the top hundred no you
said you put a burst option published
your first app when you were 12 okay
your first step not you were a blog
feature so let's do this let's do see
this argument is not helping because the
point I see is okay you want to say it
and do it on top first when I was 12
fine you can believe that
you can you can say when I was 15 you
want to believe that you said okay you
can say I built my first I was 15 if
that makes you happy that's fine that's
what you can believe I did this stuff 10
years ago if you're coming with you ask
and prove you today
I built over a hundred apps after that I
have sent you proof of 12 apps I built
well before a 12 apps before I was
turning 15 right I sent you all of that
then I sent you a lot of proof there's a
lot all of this I don't know where 100
apps till today right it's very hard if
you ask me to go back in time and tell
you what happened ten years ago I've
been bit involved with building so many
companies obviously I can't tell you the
details of that time but what honest
what I'm trying to say is that you your
press is look I I think there's just an
I think there's just an honesty problem
here because you're saying one thing and
then you change it and you change it and
you change it so you said you you use
you said you agree that your first app
was published when you were 15 years old
right yeah
your first app was published when you
were 15 right
first iPhone app published by myself yes
and that became pop pop in the toilet
okay let's talk the full facts right if
you want to put me down I want I would
appreciate it if you stop the pose I'm
trying to sort out fact from fiction
that's the whole thing okay that's fine
my app the first app according to you
that I have proven to you was when I was
October 15 2010 when I was 15 years old
I've also proven to you this app was
number one on the Indian App Store in
seven days of its launch I've sent you
that proof right it was number one in
seven days of my launch this was the
proof up I provide it was here's what I
mean here's what I'm seeing though
here's what I'm saying I'm seeing a
press site that published about you
saying that according to this these
people you created over 30 apps that
were used by millions of people before
you were even 15 and that can't be true
and I'm just trying to ask you come
clean no I had I had all these downloads
by the way when I was 15 16 but yes it's
true I agree to some part of that press
release may not be true but you have to
remember I don't control all the press
there's a lot of and that's the problem
right now do you think there are people
think I'm making stuff up about you
that's one of the biggest problems
there's a lot of misinformation right
now there's people making fake stuff and
there's people making a lot of fake
stuff and then talking [ __ ] about it so
when that Vyse and when the Weisse girl
said that you uh you were mentored by
Steve Jobs and Steve Jobs was asking you
how to make his App Store successful
she was do you think she was lying or
she miss quoted you or something I'm not
saying she miscoded me I'm not saying
she didn't if you can repeat the code
and fully beating slowly but I also
proved to you about the wife's article I
mean that's the article II used in your
first video I prove to you why save me
money I got paid by wise $3,000
to interview for them so what do you
want it if you want to go into how the
PR works I can tell you a lot about how
PR works
Weiss paid me money to do that interview
for them I told them outright it's gonna
cost me money if you if should cost you
money if you want to come and take an
interview for me at that time when Weiss
interviewed me I was in two TV shows in
America I was on Good Morning America I
had I was an already my TV show that was
the first rich convincing I'm Tanisha
was seen by millions of people it came
out so I was I had a lot more ego at
that time I'm not gonna deny it so when
they reached out so they paid me for
that article and after that they went in
purified it further I agree that article
is over glorification right I agree
that's how it looks like but I am NOT
going to do with it if they went and
made it look more than then then how it
should be my god no no don't you plan
that yeah I just want to cover that real
quick because I think it's important to
know you know I don't you know obviously
you can't control everything someone
says about you but some of these are
direct quotes from you and you say you
know Steve Jobs approached Evan to work
out how to harness the power of the
newly configured app store and then it
says he had just built the app store and
no one was using it he was just looking
for feedback and you said you told him
it's a great platform so is it true that
you approached Steve Jobs approached you
to figure out you know his app store
wasn't getting downloads it wasn't doing
well now how she's ridden it obviously
it can't be word-for-word like that she
is definitely over glorified and I'm not
denying that she's obviously the piece
looks like very overboard vacation but
yes the fact is Steve Jobs did cool he
did ask how is the App Store what is
your feedback any CEO at that time and I
I can't prove the Steve Jobs poll but I
can prove the country head of Google
which is equally as big as Apple putting
me on stage when I was 17 the country
head of Google in front of thousands of
people putting me on stage if a 17 year
old can build apps
why can't you build that country head of
Google India which is Google's biggest
market Google happens to be as big as
Apple I proof for that I don't have
proof
call but yes Steve Jobs did one and did
ask for feedback on his App Store which
is a very normal thing to do because if
you think if you go back in that time
this is the time when everybody was
using blackberry okay right black buddy
was the King Nokia was nobody Apple
became big in our generation in yours
and mine generation
so Apple was not as big so his thing his
App Store was struggling and then he was
looking for feedback from the people was
not it was not struggling I don't agree
that that's that's what angry wise
article says that you said so no that's
how they have putted it I'm not denying
that they have Allah glorified the
article but I was paid it was a paid gig
I'm not that I'm going deny them at that
time somebody note an article it paid me
three thousand dollars for it I was
happy I said okay so the thing is this I
I thought you might like say that milli
McKown which was the writer of this
piece it basically changed the words or
she over blew it but so I reached out to
milli the writer of the piece and I
asked you know was did did evan say
these things you know he's maybe
alleging that maybe he didn't say these
things because yesterday you were
telling me Steve Jobs didn't mentor you
and she said you did you said that he
did now you're saying he did but this is
what she said just for everybody
she said everything is committed to
print everything committed to print is
verified by you and recorded to audio by
myself and transcribed by vice so
according to her I mean again this comes
to who's lying here because there are
two stories being told you know it's
Steve Jobs is calling you asking how to
make the App Store better which you have
no proof of and the App Store by the way
just for everyone who is knowing it was
an instant success
there's nothing struggling about it it
had 10 million application downloads in
three days and he said I'm quoting Steve
Jobs here the App Store is a grand slam
is what he said so the app store was
never struggling and also combining that
with the fact that you didn't publish
your first app until you were 15 and so
the app store had been around for two
years so why Steve Jobs calling for I
agree on a nice quiet years later
let's ask Weiss to provide what I said
it was struggling I don't
I would have said that too so let's ask
Weiss to provide that clip where they
said I was struggling if you already in
touch with them why don't you ask them
to provide that let's ask them I mean
right and I can't do it right now let's
ask them yeah no I'll ask away
but the Paloma the boy consistently
you're kind of saying oh this isn't
right about me this isn't right when the
story the story is falling apart where
you built an app when you were 13 no
wait it wasn't an app it was my blog
within an app but actually I was the
first 100 downloads welcome there's 500
downloads right it's like what I'm
trying to get at is we've got to
separate fact from fiction here your
your whole brand is built on being
honest and building this trust with the
people who are looking at your lifestyle
there are people claiming that you're
fake but it's up to you to prove that
you're not and say these things that I
said today actually I didn't okay so
okay let's let's let's let's go on that
point he just said there's people
claiming I'm fake the only people who
are claiming that are trolls anonymous
page you're the first guy who ever stood
up but I confronted you before you the
only people who ever said anything is
behind an anonymous page and there's one
guy who stood up and that's because I
sent you proof he owes me a bunch of
money and there is there's there is
nobody who before you publicly somebody
of some influence was caught up instead
something it's always anonymous people
always take profiles on the internet and
always trolls people have followed that
for all pages and follow troll I have
had multiple big companies wet me and
give me honors do you that have that do
actual wedding actual verification give
me honors and verify stuff see I'm not
denying there's a lot of misinformation
around things and I'm not denying I may
have said something about 10 years
something happened ten years ago and you
have to remember there's a lot of
content in my life there is a lot of
content I have done so much stuff but
there's so much stuff in the past but I
have to pull up now I was telling you
about right now and I made about MIT I
was telling you I couldn't find it
because I I couldn't find the location
right now but I did I built over a
hundred apps and equities and shares in
over 50 plus apps that I I told you can
verify almost online all the companies
you asked me essentially proof I spoke
about it
here's the thing about the press think
you're talking I want to bring up the
press idea because that's the problem is
you're paying for press and so the
reality of the 21st century and
something I've been trying to tell my
subscribers is that the appearance of
success I think you'll look even agree
with this can be bought you can just buy
the appearance of success you don't have
to actually I can successfully I agree
with you 100% if you have the right
resources and the right connections you
can buy by the appearance of success I
can see it's very easy to manipulate
people today online if that's what
you're trying to get to is that if you
can menu plate people it's very very
easy to manipulate people online today
you can create news which does not exist
and most people who believe that people
believe what they read they do not check
the source of information where it's
coming from
news or yes but but news like you know
you created 30 apps before you are 15
years old because you hadn't created any
apps before you're 15 my problem is it
looks like you're trying to build up the
appearance of beings like a tech savant
from the time you were young when every
app the reality is much more normal and
what you'd expect you know what I mean
and it seems like all of the mistakes
and all the mistakes are all end up
serving you I mean like the whole thing
of oh it was just a confusion man I I
wasn't actually mentored by Steve Jobs I
just I just said I was but I meant it in
a different that's only serves your
public profile it's all to serve you but
I built a hundred apps by the time out
or thirty no it's not deserved me it's
me okay let's go to the example where
the country had a Google India pull me
up on stage right
he used me as a tool it served Google
let's be very clear
it served Google he put why do you think
he put me there were thousands of people
in the audience right why do you think
he chose me to use an example to get
people to build this was a Google's
technical event they had thousands of
developers coming there and it was all
about building apps for Android I'll
tell you why why do you think yeah
because he thought you could use me as a
tool and it would it would it would be
great for him and why he's okay Weiss
let's go to the wise
article they paid me remember I didn't
say that listen in 2016 they paid me
they used babe ID okay you want to go
deeper into the Weiss context this
article was written for Weiss
motherboard it was paid for for UBS UBS
is the end customer for whom this
content was going UBS is a private
credit to a very big bank for mostly
very wealthy individual for them this
idea using this content there's a piece
that was a parallel piece that went with
it they were serving themselves be let's
be very clear about them they were being
paid by UBS to create such kind of
content for UBS readers out of which I
was paid three thousand dollars to come
and interview me because they thought
that was interesting for their readers
but this doesn't get a rental but none
of its but not if it's boat ride but
none of its getting around like just
lies I mean at a certain point you can
say Steve Jobs is a mentor oh you want
but when the only proof you have is one
call that it doesn't seem like ever
happened because you you didn't start
with the app store
Thanks see I always said if somebody
wants to go into the details of what I
meant by the mentorship and I've said it
right in the open right I've never
denied that I've always said for me it
always was one call so if somebody wants
to go to the details that's fine it
cannot no no no but it's all about
appearance and this is where I want to
go to the doctorate sink the doctor
right dr. Evan Luthra
I mean come on man that's kind of a joke
and it goes it goes about the thing of
if anyone asks you'll say yeah it's it's
honorary but you're trying to take
credit and be seen as an expert when
you're not one blockchain I've spoken at
50-plus boxing events in 2017 so you
donate to these events of course you're
gonna speak at them no I have been paid
by a lot of these guys to speak at them
like I said it's two things I'd be paid
by golly best answer I don't donate I'm
not donating and he were free money I
always sponsored them but I get coverage
one of my company sponsors them but yes
I mean I have built a lot of companies
in the blockchain space and I sent you
the angel as company's 12th and event on
to raise 100 million dollars plus I did
most of the marketing for India
I've been involved in launching a lot of
criminal companies and Gareth Eli's with
the PhD it was because I opened a vault
first blockchain Center first when I
open in New Delhi India then I open one
in Dominican Republic then we help work
with one we open one in two if we had
only 5 % shareholding I'm studying it
openly the zero point I was just a
partner but the PhD was as a it's very
common I didn't invent this it's been
happening for hundreds of years people
donate buildings in the US and they get
a building named after them and they get
on reduction here you donate a small
room and you open a blockchain Sentra
it's the same thing but no what is wrong
in that nobody who gets an honorary
Doctorate calls themself I know a lot of
people in India who do that maybe it's
different in your side of the world but
I know a lot of people who have already
doctorates in India and they have the
word doctor in front of them so they
don't you again don't you think that
it's disrespectful to the people who
spent 7 8 10 years of their life
studying something to come in with a
little bit of money fund a little Center
which has nothing to do with actually
knowing anything about blockchain and
then just claiming you have a an
honorary doctorate in boxing which you
say you have a PhD
it's a doctorate though which is not the
same thing yeah
no see it's a if you could consider it
an insult if somebody would want to take
it like that I agree maybe somebody
doesn't like it but that shouldn't stop
me from I did not break any rules are
it's not illegal to if you if you get a
lottery doctor and you can't put the
word doctor that's what it does it's
done here so it's not illegal but again
this goes back to the idea that it just
furthers the idea that you're trying to
make yourself seem like something that
you're not well me I don't have on I
don't have any kind of debris at any
university so for me this is better like
I I rather it for me to feel that I
didn't go to universities I don't have
any any kind of don't claim though don't
make it seem like you did don't make it
seem like you got the highest education
you don't know but I give I give
speeches all the time I tell people I
dropped out the first thing in my speech
is always I'm a dropout and then I say
have Omri doctorate place only place but
the problem is is you don't always say
you have an honorary Doctorate and
you're throwing this doctor in front of
your name which you don't deserve you've
never
you've never earned our I burnt it
that's that's that's the point I'm
coming to its feet yes for you maybe
it's not okay that's your point and I'm
willing to listen to your point I'm not
denying that you think I've not earned
it that's fine but I do believe that
I've done enough in the black screen
space to deserve that I do believe that
I have may I was very early in the box
in space also I bought my first big 20
2012 I have done and been involved in
growing a lot of companies in the
flashiest very early on and I think it I
think it's a fit fit monitor so I don't
think why I cannot have it I mean I
think I told you the example when we had
this chat yesterday that you can even
buy the title Lord right you can buy the
title Lord if you if you if you buy a
five square feet by five square feet
piece of land in Scotland a tradition
you're meant to be habitat alone so this
is again a what a certain way around
what you said well if I hadn't but do
you understand this can come off like a
like a like a poser or like somebody's
showing image of success instead of
actually being successful let me let me
just finish what I was coming to sure I
would I buy I bought that lot title very
simple I do 125 every year I get better
service at airport so if I found a way
if life you got a better service and
move ahead and I use that way and I felt
I feel it's still okay that's acceptable
when I feel if somebody else has read a
matter is what if you if you have the
title Lord in front of your name then
hotels and airports they treat you
better maybe they would they would
because the senior bookings you can use
their title so you call heaven Lutheran
in some of the bookings where I'm going
I could use the title because I legally
bought a piece of land in Scotland and
it allows me to use that it's a life
hack that I've found and I used in my
benefit this it's it's if nobody's
telling you these things doesn't mean
you can't use them this is what I've
learned in my life I think it's a great
way I think if somebody else can get
that go for it
I think though that you have to
understand that people are gonna are
gonna call you a faker I'm looking at
one of your things from your I think
this is your angel
Coe
or it's one of your listings your
profiles where you have Evan Luthor
entrepreneur investor 24 PhD the best
way to predict the future is to build it
nothing about it being honorary buddy
I mean that's lying maybe in what up
know lot of these profiles are not made
by me so this is a team working behind
it see again I said openly there's
Audrey doctrine I'm telling you I agree
there would be some people who would be
in like I said to you most people don't
don't read the details they don't work
but you're not in the details
your Instagram doctor I've been single I
can't put everything everywhere that's
not put everything there's no there's no
limit to have to remove something else
to put it
do you know what a limit to five do you
know the word Auto rates you know what a
purple heart is I do not know what that
is okay it's a one of the highest awards
when you are in the army here and you
get injured and they give you a Purple
Heart and I'm like in battle right it's
this really prestigious award that is
like really respected right let's say
I'm in the Army I'm sitting at a desk
job and I get a paper cut I don't have a
Purple Heart because I got a paper cut
working for the army right the award
means something it implies sacrifice it
actually has a level of respect given to
it because of the exclusivity of the
thing and you're sort of stomping all
over that and saying oh yeah it's fine
because it's technically not illegal
well it's oddly a douchebag move but and
you say it nobody you're talking about
auditory work or hard
it's in my leaned in it says honor it's
on my website it says honorary
things which I control my bedside it
says monetary things we just linked in
it says honorary I can't put honoree in
my Instagram because it doesn't have
that much space I would put it if I if I
had that space I don't know what to say
I'd the best way to predict the future
is building things I'm more important to
me if somebody wants do the research
click the link turn editing on what it's
half and you open my website and it says
the first paragraph so I mean again I
believe I got it and I have a right to
do it it's not it's not me who invented
the concept of honorary Purple Heart I
didn't embed back before me there's been
housed
people having tens of thousands of
people whether an ordinary purple hats
and I am ten thousand one in line and if
I'm using it and again it's in your
culture I know a lot of people who put
it in front of them doctor even though
they are on I've you never see you're
not that and I would call him maybe just
as dumb that is I'm telling you right
now it's I'm just telling you honestly
just late I meet a lot of what Americans
are doing this third a third party
perspective you should stop doing that
because it's just embarrassing
when people actually [ __ ] out it's
embarrassing okay let's do this I agree
what you're saying I'll go halfway
through I'll remove the doctor from
Instagram because it's not clear and
full like I said I'm open to the
criticism drop a doctor altogether
you're not a doctor you have no
expertise in blockchain you've never
done a paper
you've never research a PhD in blah I
don't claim I my neck I play my honorary
PhD I wish we could rewind that eighteen
seconds ago when you said you are an
expert in blockchain yes and I've proven
things I've done so it's been said by a
lot of people I agree with that part too
but I believe if I'm if I'm claiming
it's honorary PhD when I voted maps and
events everywhere I would be okay I
think I would be happy to claim its
honor a PhD I write that in the events
in the bio so it's sort of like I should
be fun it's you're an expert but you're
not an expert is what I'm hearing no so
let's no let's agree with you what do
you think should should not I shouldn't
be allowed to claim honorary PhD I
should be okay according to you if it
says honorary that's the concept first I
think it says honorary doctorate but it
doesn't mean you can be a doctor doctor
and anytime you ever use the word
doctorate or anything
honorary goes before it I don't care if
you have don't have enough characters
don't put it buddy but also it's just
not it's just not a thing that you
really like stand on it's kind of a
weird I'm just I'm just telling you how
it looks from the outside I don't want
to stay on this topic kind of forever
because I don't think it's it's super
important but I just wanted to tell you
that it's like it's just insulting to
everyone who's actually done the work
right that's that's what it is
you might see it as a live act but it's
insulting I mean we'll agree to disagree
there's let's leave it there
I will I will take your feedback and I
will remove it from the Instagram the
doctor I will remove that if you feel
that's the way and I'll leave it
honoring and I'll try to be a better
person today onwards from you there you
go
okay fair enough so let's see here
there's also the story of so one thing I
want to talk about now is talk about
some now that we've established sort of
why there's some some pate around you
it's because there are holes in your
story right there's things that don't
make sense there are things that are
actually not true here not true there so
now let's move on to sort of your your
business right what you're in the
business of and and talk about that
because I think it's really important
you know I wouldn't care if you're
saying these things but you're not
taking investments things like that but
you're building yourself up and then
you're taking investments from people so
you have a company called start startup
sorry I don't want to get this wrong
startup school startup studio yeah I
wanted to ask you a few questions about
that and I first want to get into like
the allegations made against you
and let me finish and then you can jump
in and maybe correct whatever so three
people came to me and said that you took
significant amounts of money from them
and the idea was you're going to build
an app for them okay just for everyone
listening at home and you are going to
both build the app and invest a
significant amount of money into their
company okay and they allege that you
basically overcharge them and took the
money they were making you didn't tell
them that you were gonna build a bad app
in India and not spend much money and
they were expecting a lot more and they
got a bad product delivered so I think
one of them lost $80,000 one of them
lost $170,000 and I think he might have
gone temporarily homeless I mean it was
pretty serious and in another one lost
like a hundred thousand dollars or
something I I don't have these factors
completely right okay but they gave you
all this money under the idea that
you're going to build an app and then
basically they got sort of subpar apps
out of it and I sort of wanted to ask
you about that because in light of sort
of these I don't want you if you want to
call them lies or half-truths about your
experience in this space what do you
think what what are your responses to
those people and then I want to talk
about like why you only get 20% of their
investment if you're investing so much
money so you want to respond real quick
yes sure very happy to go into details
about this now there's three people that
the model you talked about there's three
people that you have talked to and I
sent you six case studies of people I've
been all been very happy you read their
recommendation I told you can contact
them I said sure the proof before I've
built our apps with pot or 50 different
founders today where I've had
partitioning people with a country with
an idea if I like the idea I invest
significant part of the ayah and then
they invest I ask them to invest a lot
less I invest four to five times the
money they invest and ask them to invest
a lot less because I need to have them
skin in the game for me it's more about
they're committed I've already proven to
you investments that I hold just to
investment that you have seen of Angeles
or whatever ten million dollars just the
easy investment one single investment
that then you can verify that AngelList
and they have funds in able to identify
that I sent you the angel dog holding it
says why I ain't released that proves me
the money was sent to angel at this and
to ease I don't know how much but I said
to the doc I don't know how much you
invested in ease I couldn't but maybe I
couldn't find okay okay but you verified
that I was invest you didn't buy for the
amount you verified that I was doing you
said you invested with fresh VC and I
can yeah which is the okay that's the
fun I sent you okay
I'm happy to send you that stuff it's
all there you stops are verifiable okay
companies I've been wrestling companies
which I have shares worth tens millions
of dollars
I don't need to scam somebody for three
hundred thousand dollars right now and
don't need to do that these guys mail
they these guys failed because their
companies fail because of them I've had
a lot of success to show I have partners
we're built apps fit you have invested
money in that I've invested money in
that the same kind of deals with these
ten twenty people more thirty people
more than these three people and a lot
of them have had good success and great
success a lot of my failed that's under
Sanibel and they still have good things
to say about me because they realize why
the app failed but here's the here's why
the nice life understand here's the part
that I don't understand okay and I want
everyone to get this real quick
okay so these people come to you and a
lot excuse me
a lot of times they're not like super
old like I know one of them was like 16
or 17 when he approaches you right a kid
a kid with an idea okay and he tells you
about this idea he has nothing okay and
this is your business model it makes no
sense you say hey you give me 20% of
your company and I'll invest hundreds of
thousands of dollars into this app that
doesn't exist I'll invest four times
what you are investing so this guy
invested like a hundred thousand
whatever invested and you claim to
another play-doh vest hold on hold on
that's half a million dollars for 20% of
a kid's company that makes yes it that's
not invest normal in okay that's how
that if you if if I take if I take a big
part of your company think of it from my
perspective right if I end up taking 80%
of their company and giving them 20%
then they have no reason to keep working
to make that company big because they
have multiple rounds of investment
there's theories feed round that they're
a Series A Series B Series C Series B
they will keep losing at for your long
product you're talking about a company
that did really did not exist at all I
mean it was just an idea just an idea
with no cash flow no revenue diversify
hundreds of investments and then wait
for that Musha like ease like hash crap
which give me a hundred x that's the
business model you invest in a lot of
companies and then you wait for the
companies to grow because installer its
immensity you got half ninety five
percent of companies will fill that's
obviously I gotta talk to you gotta let
me talk because the Devils in the
details here right because what they're
claiming is that they put in $100,000
ninety thousand dollars and their app
only actually cost $90,000 did I let me
speak okay because we can't talk over
each other we won't get anywhere so I
agree twenty percent you there they're
investing like 90
dollars and most a lot of apps cost
about that range and then you take 20%
of the copyright on top of that on top
of that you are Clint you're claiming to
have invested half a million dollars
into their company okay you're claiming
to invest half a million dollars for 20%
of a company that doesn't really exist
without you doing all the work you're
doing all the work you're investing I'm
not doing what we're taught four times
before times the money right all they
have is the idea and you're claiming to
only get 20% it doesn't add up it
literally it makes no sense okay let me
from my person because after you one by
one then people asking questions one by
one all the points because you already
made three points right the first thing
is I'm not doing most of the work I'm
doing very little work make my money is
doing a lot of work for me I'm my people
I have hundreds of developers working
they're building the app remember
there's people building the app they
build up and they're the people it's the
responsibility of the founder to run the
app and these three guys companies
failed because they were unable to do
that not once
if my app had failed this Noah guy would
not have come back to me for a second
back he had a second dad he came back to
me for a second app I'm at a new deal
with him I loaned him money
but Larry cookie let me complete let me
complete I want to come to all your
points I'm gonna company he came back to
me for a second back it's not if I was
doing back 40 up to him he would have
not come back for a second that and he
got me into it a similar agreement again
in which he didn't pay me he did a loan
so he basically I invested fully my life
and he's young guy that's why I need him
please go invest because I mean if you
have skin in the game if he's not going
messing tomorrow he walks away so he
came back for a second act with me well
back into an agreement the second
agreement he went back inside and
notarized and I sent you that agreement
that's that's my the other party these
guys at any points they could have gone
to the phone you never went to quote
okay I'm not the point about your how
you claim the app was ninety thousand
that's not how it works it cost fifty
thousand dollars to buy a car yeah but
you can buy a Rolls Royce for $500,000
or you can buy a Toyota Prius for
$20,000 it depends what you are buying
and and you talk to three people who
talk [ __ ]
the only money on contract that's the
reason I'd give you numbers of six
people I give you pay studies I give you
recommendations I told you to go and ask
I told you do your research and talk to
all these people have built apps with
and I'm building after the right now
what is their experience and you already
know you've seen that my absolute up
free apps before featured by Apple so
the cost of my apps now in these people
knew what was the deal they knew the
terms from the first day it was a
contract to sign it that stays this is
how much that is going to cost do you
agree or do you not agree and this is
how much it's going to cost is how much
I'm going to put in and this you don't
go to rolls-royce later and tell them yo
you're crashing up Constance I wonder
should cost is 400,000 give me a hundred
thousand back
that's not how business is done it was
all my avatar others were forty five
years old running for present MP ins our
apartment like no I were 17 years old
no I had a great idea he had a very big
wish and I fell for that wishing but
he's delusional I mean it's in the I
don't know again again though it's not
making any sense you're taking a 17 year
old kid and you're investing well this
kid has a hundred thousand hundred
change thousand dollars in the app
you're investing I think half a million
dollars for 20% of the company and then
you your company whether you want to say
you did the work or your company did
work your company's doing most of the
work for 20% of the company I don't
think so it doesn't matter when the math
doesn't you're not honey some things
brought something's wrong
no no right no no but you're not you're
not count no you're not I'm not doing
any of the work the work is to run the
app but it was what building apps I
could build a hundred after myself
without needing partners I need those
partners to run the company and I'm
happy they keep 80% for that because out
of ten one works
they give me a hundred X out of twenty
one works
they give me a hundred that's how
startup investments work look at all the
why do you think ten years ago the five
biggest companies in the world and
fifteen years ago were all oil companies
around 2005 in five biggest company the
US for all oil companies I feel like
we're now it's all right here so like
we're going off-track no no no I'm not
going off-track I'm giving you in why
technology is the fastest growing
industry in the world but
that's off-track logic is the quick
because let me let me come to my point
no you need to understand why how about
business mother works to comment on my
business model you don't understand it
yet okay you don't know because that's
what I'm saying you can do it ideas no
you do not
people come to me with ideas led to
technology if I like the idea I say I'm
investing in it and I build it for them
but it's their job to run the business
if their I've successfully run the
business my ROI is a hundred X because I
was there very early on and I get but
majority of these people will fail
that's understood because that's how
startup investment swirled majority of
the startups do fill but the ones which
work that's why we have the Airbnb
that's why we have the Twitter's that's
why we have the easiest buy we have the
Facebook they work they give you crazy
returns if you invested in uber feed
round alright we're good $5,000 go we're
really going to million Tommy let me say
what I think's going on okay and I'll
tell you what I think is going on i but
you share a good source of knowledge
it's I'm open to listening to you but
like I said before verify your
information before making allegations
check your source so I'm happy listening
that's why I'm just explaining no it's
it's just it this is just logic right
this is just logic right logically it
doesn't make sense to go just to a kid
who has who has money he ends up making
sense if you go to one kid if you do -
once he doesn't make sense if you know
the numbers are out of 100 kids five
kids it'll guarantee go 100x and you may
500 times your money even if you give
the money to 100k and he said always 100
kid and no I was no joke if he had a
hundred thousand at that time lying
around
he claims right now online he made forty
two million dollar problem the pro I
believed in a or on heaven so my
partners are wanting to present okay
our partners were running from where -
election our partners were very very
successful have very good businesses I
sent you case studies you did not do
your time can go through them and I sent
your contact so you read the case
studies you have - you saw some of my
path right yes yes yes guys were 40
years old IIT in studies for the biggest
universities and they built good apps I
build the apps my company build apps not
me
my company build apps I went on to race
for the funding I have my model work
great i what a great return on it but
the man only works if you diversify
enough investment I don't think why they
don't think it any investor serious
investor will look at this and say it
makes sense to give a four times
investment on what the initial take an
idea that really doesn't exist yet
that's really just an app idea invest
four times what the founders investing
and then only get 20% as you build the
app for them I don't think that makes
sense but we're gonna have to leave it
there because ultimately it's a it's
exactly the working great dummy model
you say you say it is but it's like we
don't actually know if you're successful
because we don't know how much money
you've lost we don't know how much of
this money is your dad's money I mean
the whole problem is is you've bought a
lot of claims that a lot of them have
turned out to be true so what's our
reason to believe anything you say
you call yourself a doctor no except my
father my link this is our adoption it's
again see the point is up to you what
you want to believe it's up to you wanna
do the research it's all there
do your research talk to Noah see his
company failed why it failed why has he
not gone to quote why is none of these
three people I went to court if I lost
them the money this paperwork says
agreements why are they hiding behind
anonymous because it's hard to sue
people in India and they probably don't
have a lot of money a bit and you know a
lot of money the company no no I have
companies in the US my friend they sign
a copy of the US and yeah but your
contract says that the arbitration
clause is in India so they invited in
India maybe it means so even they wanted
but don't lock an adult lie because your
your contract says that they have to
fight it in India so I am and they can't
Surya India because everyone knows yeah
good luck getting that off the ground
yeah and as I said these people are
castrated so what recourse do they
really have right that's the problem
that's why I don't like when people take
people's money who are struggling when
sell them the identification is I sent
you a contract mate which clearly says
he owes me two hundred thousand dollars
today after interest anyways anybody
anybody if they wanted to come out to me
for the money they could legally come
but they have no higher bring it up
they're broke and they have to go to
India good luck you say well no you pick
the pre example I told you what no I
sensual contract that's very fiber at
Smith's Natori that he loves me money
second McGuinn he came after me legally
his legal team came after me send me a
notice I send that animal is his own
legal team left him his legal team left
him because they do they everything he
know that's not true
I've talked to this guy he goes I was
behalf game he goes he goes I was broke
I couldn't pay for any more hours on my
lawyer because you have a track record
of lying here we've established a matter
of credibility it's a matter of
credibility and when you're coming to me
saying you're mentored by Steve Jobs you
know I'm telling us let's not leave this
point you put three people who said bad
things about me about my deals right two
of them one of them owes me money
legally other one tried to come after me
legally his lawyers left him he's broke
the third why broke nobody he had the
money to pay the lawyer that's why
that's why he came out he bit him I need
a lawyer
the lies in the world I don't have to
work for free he sent me a notice asking
for money back and coming up with all
these [ __ ] claims that this attorney
did this did that and know once I sent
him the responses with the contracts
there was no hearing back this was over
a year ago actually
so the third battery I had a chat with
him I never knew that he was really
saying bad things about me until you
told me yesterday in the first person
you told me so I talked to him yesterday
and asked him he's he's discontent and I
don't I think Petry stood a chance to
make the app work so I'm stupid uncle
reductive but I maintain these apps
failed because of my partner's not
putting it not because of me
if these apps were successful Miguel
would be buying me a yacht today I would
be buying me a [ __ ] jet that's how it
would be obviously his I've been worked
out and he's putting the blame on me you
built the app yeah but it was approved
by Apple it was working fine jump any
crappy app that gets approved by Apple
does it no it's the rolls-royce I was
building if I was building shitty app I
wouldn't be I wouldn't have had the
previous six I had you already know I
wouldn't have the previous success I had
my apps wouldn't be that good see okay
this is again we kind of come to a
disguise
yeah I don't I don't want to argue the
whole time yeah we come out here what
move on let's move on to another topic
okay what is it what is the biggest app
that you've ever personally built that
like we would know that the first the
most downloads the most downloads purely
based on most downloads if you consider
would be the ICC Cricket World Cup app I
built and it had millions and millions
of downloads but I got sued by ICC it
was removed in 15 days I had to transfer
the whole code base to ICC over because
I used the logo without knowing that I
had no rights to use the logo the app
before it was taken over by ICC now
there's there's this this was actually a
big case when I was 16 years old at a
very big learning experience
I used the logo of ICC Cricket World Cup
and launched an app for the World Cup
without their permission
but before they took over the app from
me it already had millions of down eight
and it was very very high it was the
number one app in Australia in Pakistan
in India because you're leveraging
someone else's fame and then just making
a quick app on it of course it's gonna
get no downloads but that's a successful
or interesting gap it just means it has
a lot of downloads and it was a free no
but it was not okay no no it was a free
app it was get people could see the
scores they could follow the live
welcome that was happening it was
providing value I had more dots than the
ICC normal app official app that's why
they sued me they let me go without
paying them any money because I was 16 I
gave them all the users I gave them
everything and this is a model that
that's how I got one of my only success
I did you saw that I built a for two and
a Half Men the TV show I both have four
Gossip Girls the TV show I've built out
where the communities could come and
engage yes I've got hundreds of
thousands of dollars and it became
number what top three and why and all
the screenshots that you sent me I mean
like there they say you know they're the
top free a paisa do see that on the like
different categories and different
categories but the problem is is that
they have no ratings why don't they have
any ratings in these screenshots because
these free shots is because these
screenshots came in the first two three
days when I published the app and that's
what I'm saying at that time the apps
shot up to the top downloads and there
were no ratings that were posted in that
time usually you have to wait up you
have to wait before the rating show
but discreet they are there you want to
verify this I sent you the proof you can
call up Apple and verify you can reach
out to them best proof is there for you
I'm not denying that that proof is there
use apps Gossip Girl two and a Half Men
I made for you lie to me a few more TV
shows I made at that time that's what
I'm saying it's so back in the past and
all of these apps became the top in the
category and a hundreds of thousands of
dollars okay we don't have we don't when
I bill don't we don't have any
verifications on hundreds of thousands
all we have is screenshots that say no
ratings they are at the top but you have
the top okay but they shot by the top
your horse by but there but there's no
rating so I don't okay look you I don't
know what to make a bit honestly okay
let's do this let's do this you're going
verify this from Apple you go and verify
this from Apple that's on you if you
want to make allegation about say like I
was trying to look at the apps time
giving heating up Evan Luther industries
I couldn't find anything this is 2015
this is not there anymore this 2015 you
would have to reach out to Apple and ask
them I told you this is mm my mind I
haven't built an app since I was 18 my I
haven't heard a single line of code I
haven't written a single head of code
since I was 18 that's why I asked you
when you said AB that I have built would
be back in the past now I don't build
myself I have another first dealing for
me okay let me be clear then what app
has your company built that we would all
know okay so now you have talked about
well I want to pluck some of the apps
that we have been recently involved in
which I know I don't want plugs no plugs
sorry buddy okay you I mean go go check
out Dave bomb it's great for your
audience you can download games it's us
us-based app where you can download
games and play games and you can bet
money and you win real money on the game
it's called game foam GME frm you can
download on the App Store then we don't
need the plug just the name is fine
thank you very much Jesus I was I would
think where my company has built would
you say that I've invested in it also or
I've not invested in my no no you would
will because the quality of your baps
that you build your okay if you want to
talk about building notice so then we
have built a lot of high quality app you
build up a fortune 500 companies which
you built for boy I was thinking for
just one name maybe that game form is
okay citibank we design city banks app
there you go that's what be my biggest
that should be the biggest Belle known
brand name let it work with me okay well
after I would even say yeah I'm happy to
give you the proof for that too sure and
even Google there you know even Google
is on stage I built that for Google's
event there you go that's also there
it's a pretty big name so they they they
they think my apps for good enough and
they still think it's good enough real
quick these three guys no no let's
finish this off they think maps are good
enough and they still think my I'm good
enough and I still have companies saying
me and I'm happy to show you the
document you refuse to sign the NDA I
sent you five messages can you sign the
NDA you said you don't want to see that
I said you I'll send you the contract I
sent you a bunch of contracts already
I'm not gonna sign da as we're about to
go live on a show where I have to bring
up ever if you're wonderful you're
proven yet that the proof is behind an
NDA I mean because I am a min I am in
contrast to a lot of people I caught no
no no it's obviously I can't show and I
don't know how many million dollar deals
you're fine
I sent you a few already they're having
two million dollar deals that's true
so I've done a lot of that essentially
someone for without India is but numbers
to learn I mean I can send you bank
statements but are there combination II
clauses there are confidentially clauses
well you cannot reveal something without
putting the party you applied that party
thing are these honorary million dollar
deals are the real million dollar deals
there I have given you numbers I've give
I received millions dollars of fields
just in the last one month 30 days
I chose actions with edges I've given
you numbers you can verify that I give
you the numbers and you said Bennett
before you on the call let's get a live
if you want let's talk about that
speaking of million dollar deals let's
talk about coronavirus right coronavirus
is a kind of hot topic right now and
there's a lot of word about fake stuff
getting sent out and getting proposed to
be like that people pretend it's real
and sell it as real but it's actually
not real it's not legit and they're
saying it is right and so you've been
affiliated with you you've told me I
want to be clear to the audience right
now Evan does not manufacture any kind
of PPE anything
like that but he does sell it like as a
third party like I guess intermediary I
think you'd call yourself writing it's
trading right role cream created correct
okay
and you've sent out like brochures based
on those things to get people interested
and stuff like that
and I want to bring one of these things
to your attention because I was looking
up you know oh one of the important
things when you're selling coronavirus
stuff is it has to be legit like that's
the most rapid has to be certified if
you sell something that's not certified
so it's not a it's not a civil offense
it's a criminal offense you can go to
jail for that right if you sell a
medical item if you sell a mask right
and you say it's a chronal RS mask and
somebody wears it and they die and you
you sell it I go into trouble so I'm not
stupid kind of going to trouble for
basic masks when I've shown you I'm
making millions of dollars right so the
same stuff so that's really what I want
to talk about today cuz I want to talk
about these these tests so so there's a
brochure on your coronavirus testing kit
- that was part of audre health tech
where it was FDA certified I'm gonna
pull that up for everybody right now FDA
certified right there boom there's
certificate of registration yada yada
the problem with that though is that uh
it's it's fake that's a fake testing kit
certification it's a fake test immediate
certification I'm gonna link it in chat
real quick for everybody who wants don't
click off the stream you guys but check
that out it's a it's a fake
certification it actually is from a mask
supplier so this this is a fake
screenshot pretending to be certifying a
test kit that is actually straight off
of a mask from China so they took a mask
FDA certification and pretended that
their coronavirus test was real Kimmy
can you agree that that is a scumbag
thing to do in a time of crisis okay
let's if if there was something sold or
somebody bought something in the first
that would become bad thing to do I give
you proof I was always a consultant for
order health care I always essentially
that before you asked me we never sold
any testing kits I sell you that before
we never saw we marketed it if somebody
is sending us certificates remember we
don't manufacture the way these deals
work you're not being involved in any
deal let me tell you how these deals
work and for everybody else watching me
listen listen you guys not been involved
you're commenting without knowing and
that's irresponsible so let me let me
educate you because I have experience
I've done this you repeat it so yeah
exactly and you didn't want you whatever
you want to pick a PhD points you failed
to call any of the people I sent you the
numbers to verify their soul their
millions of math and stuff in time of
their need you fail to do that okay let
me let me say it cause nobody answered
but that's not a separate thing okay so
you never told me that
I asked you many times you never told me
that okay I would have put you in cars
right away anyways how these deals work
we get content from this from the
manufacturer this is our stuff this our
certificate you want to let me put them
in presentation not this me not doing
this this team's doing this I've got the
brochures I said it forward once the
buns to buy the grief he likes something
then they do the verifications at that
point I'm dealing with hundreds of
brokers daily utilizes hundreds of
brokers every other day I'm talking to
you to source this stuff they're sending
me stuff we put that in a brochure we
send it forward once a deal happens at
that step the verification is done I've
had lots of deals falls apart because
brokers and fake certificate that's
happened between many many times and
that's normal that's how these deals
happen no deal happens no buyer is
paying millions of dollars without
verifying the stuff that he's buying
without verifying the kids no bar is
doing that if anybody is doing that bad
for him I'm a broker I get paid a
commission
I don't manufacture any of these masks I
don't manufacture any of his kids I
don't certify these kids I don't do any
of that I'm a broker I connect the
manufacturer with the buyer with the
buyer and but you listen me don't you
think you to sin no I okay I'm not gonna
verify everything that's coming to me
but it is a complicated of a
verification let me tell you how long it
took me to find out
that long and I'm not understanding I
wouldn't do that if you're selling this
stuff no I'm not comparing those
brochures buddy you're not understanding
I'm not preparing those brochures
because you're selling it so I am
getting it from somebody and I just test
you don't get my testing kit to I only
trust the kid there's trust to get one
the company
audre health tech is authorized I've had
them to sell that testing kit
they're only issue that came up was one
certificate is faking one of the kids
bar I would know that and we would know
that before we start with the buyer you
would know that if this kid was actually
ordered by somebody but it was never
ordered and it was never moved forward
we have like this testing kit two three
four five six we get content you send it
forward and once the deal closes that's
when you go into verifying if it's real
there or not because you don't realize
how many are moving everyday so you're
advertising before you know if the thing
that you're selling is legit is what
you're telling me no this has sometimes
people said we don't think the people
sending us a fake certificate sometimes
it happened out of how many of them okay
let's let's talk about how much pee pee
I've delivered millions are mass
sanitizers coveralls have what you call
gloves two people have to go to
governments to hospital to old-age home
in times of their need you don't want to
talk about that no I haven't been able
to verify it
I know I said you I said I said to you -
what if I sent you contracts I sent you
is sine inverse and if you want to send
you you can okay you want to verify now
I'll call somebody now you can call any
of the numbers I sent you right now
let's see the answers the problem is
this you can sell a lot of stuff and if
it's not legit that's a problem do you
think I would come back to me listen I'm
talking about buyers who have bought
from me for a hundred thousand dollars
in the range
I delivered they were happy they came
back a second eye for a million dollars
less range and then they came back at
now they're coming back to me for a deal
which is much bigger and this all is
crap and Lebanon do you think I would be
getting these deals for these
transactions if I was selling fake stuff
that's there's people going after people
daily this fake case this accusations
were made by me ul and Noah because they
have nothing better to do no you think
I'm the one who found they were fake no
no
I don't get the original source and the
other thing too is there's also these uh
these also these in ninety nine masks
from audre health that are not actually
in 99 ms that's not an in 99 mask but
they're advertising so it's late what
that how can you okay I'm a broker for
Audra Audra is not my company I'm a
broker there's so many products I so
imagine you just seem to keep showing up
at the scene of the crime and each time
you're like wow it wasn't really I don't
have any accountability mate yeah no
listen listen listen I've done hundreds
I mean hundreds of companies do you
think 100 are going to be all clean and
very successful no there will be a few
stuff that goes long along the way
there's a lot what happens when you know
there's not there's a lot of success
let's be clear there's a lot of success
you verified also it's not lies perhaps
and 15 is new stuff is not lie there's
not there's a lot of stuff which went
wrong and there's people aren't happy
and there's some stuff
so again yes there's my Audra I was
always a broken
they said this is this is there the
proof is there I didn't say I sent you
projects of odd writing signed them I'm
gonna authorize team nutri I'm not I'm
not a part of the company I have zero
percent sure in the company are you
welcome to take an L on Audra health
tech that they maybe didn't have the
right sort of didn't have it that I
agree that could have been bad better I
just wanted to see your taken out I just
want to see you admit hey hey hey
there's something going on here there's
something shady I agreed that process
could have been done better in the way
they should have tested a certificate
from every broker before coming but at
the times like this where we are
responsible for getting so many goods to
people in need you contract everything
that comes to you you just cannot if we
have teams in place I can't check what
my team is doing if they haven't done
the proper job and at this time I have
to be dependent on some people I'm a
one-man
I can't also make the brochures off of
the suppliers also shake the
certificates
also to the buyer also shipping company
I can't do everything on the process I
mean I think I think the bare minimum is
making sure that when you're selling
coronavirus gear it's not nothing is
being sold before very fine I'm not
gonna be put but again I'm not
advertising it either I am NOT
I people send me okay I posted my
Instagram link all the stuff that we're
selling that was pre-populated from
address people right pre-populated
something comes a lot of people saw
thousands of people one of the that
Google Excel sheets you saw the product
me a lot of queries you talked to a lot
of people obviously it was mistakes made
where something was published where the
broker certificates but not right that's
fine we agree okay that could have been
done better we're doing it better now
now we're doing a lot better now we
don't do anything advance payment I've
lost money with brokers where I paid
suppliers didn't do I feel I feel I feel
like I feel like this is gonna also go
in circles so let's move on there's one
last topic I want to touch and this
topic might be I don't know what you
want to call it but it's kind of like I
don't know what you want to call it I
mean I I want to be polite here but um
kind of behavior that suggests that
maybe you're calibrating at a strange
level that's like your way to the egos
too big or something so there's a bunch
of screenshots that have been got gotten
out that you're claiming that you like
control presidents that you know Trump
okay that you know Nicki Minaj and these
things tend to they seem like delusional
behavior and do you want a comment on
those are you yes yes I'm happy to
comment this is delusional behavior from
a dilution of the guy in Noah this
screenshot of scan and reveals this guy
he's posted is a fake screenshot he's
made up so much [ __ ] about me he's made
of all this cold testing kids all this
stuff is made at the bottom because he
don't know what the covert test isn't
made up that's real I mean you really no
not this no no no not this certificate
stuff people post the stuff about me
selling fake stuff about co-ed before
right on this bothers Buster face your
poster stuff that's what I'm talking
about
those those that's all the acquisitions
were made by Noah maybe the certificate
you found that's okay I'm agreeing that
could be wrong what I'm saying is before
it was no all this [ __ ] was basically
the same stuff though the baller
Buster's posted is just what I confirmed
with finals or the certificate was fake
so exactly so there's all this all this
Noah's making of a lot of this fake
stuff about me all this fake screenshots
because he owes me money
I don't see I don't see that it's fake
though no it's it's screenshots he said
fake
I'm telling you I sent you he directly
blackmail him he said if you know if you
cancel my contract if you let me go for
this money I'll delete all of this this
was his place and you I sent you a
contract which you can call the Swiss
notary government entities fiddling
government they will verify to you how
much he owes me they will verify to you
he owes me he's doing a blackmail play
it so he's delusional
he's trying to blackmail me to get out
of saying what he owes me I was my hands
were tied because the contract could
only be enforced after may 1st 2020 and
now that Court is ended it's still there
I mean I am out of the caucus I can you
know with you when when I see things
like this Evan Luther Assange I just met
with Mike Pompeii in my last trip to New
York next seeing Trump soon and you were
the top of my agenda I just see a Saudi
who would also say that they're mentored
no any jobs though I didn't say that I
didn't say that though no but that's
what I'm saying he tries to go down
things which are relevant and makes turn
that vast appoint misinformation okay
buddy if if today I go Poe screenshots
on Yahoo about you saying something
would you believe it I can do that I can
do that right so that's the thing so you
are now believing what a delusional guy
who owes me money on contract blackmail
but it's very clear hold on hold on
though hold on let me explain though
there's a pattern of sort of delusional
behavior going on here that you create
that misinformation let me finish
delusional guys let me finish that
you're mentored by Steve Jobs when in
fact you absolutely were not the one
phone call me clear back and then also
from other sources I have similar
delusional behavior going on with the
screenshot screenshot that says Nicki
Minaj will tell her
a hundred million plus followers later
this week to go follow me that's another
entrance oh my god I'll announce this on
my story I announced it on my Instagram
story
I paid Nicki Minaj thirteen thousand
dollars to do an Instagram promotion
this was on my story he used that to
make it into a screenshot
public news everybody knows Nicki Minaj
cardi B did a giveaway where they told
people to go follow me it was it was
already done it was it was a useless
news to create all this stuff and any
posted on this page that's it's a
misinformation campaign constantly to
gather up a contract that you can verify
now he owes me two hundred thousand
dollars this was done by this hater or
whatever this wasn't simple it was done
by him he's pulled these screenshots on
his scan reveals page he runs that page
it's in the bio screenshot for you
that's where I saw them so if you go
there these are this is where he posts
all these fake screenshot and maybe
other people get from there then
releases I believe it's actually from I
believe it's from a jet smarter group
maybe I think get smarter group I am
part of one just might a look nothing
like that ever been posted there we can
go in right now okay I don't know okay
so there you go so again there's no
source netting you don't know where it's
from and you believe in a screen show
but you but you see me believing that
you're saying Nicki Minaj really did
tell her 100 I didn't say that I posted
on my story that Nicki Minaj is shouting
me out and then somebody made a
screenshot based on that a Nicki Minaj
did and then so did cardi be like this
is normal I did something and people
that's the whole thing that's happening
you don't see that people are turning
things around which I am NOT doing
they're learning but but again your
again it's it's you consistently showing
up at the scene of the crime
you're also saying that the person I
said you created 30 a because I'm your
15 was also no no no so let's go back to
the point no no no you now you're cheap
I don't know what I'm saying over and
over again you're saying oh no that's
not the right information no that's not
the right information this is made of
nobodies this is a mistake at what point
this is it no these people are creating
this stuff happening Nicki Minaj did
give me a shout out cardi B did give me
a shot at I posted about this on my
story then somebody goes and makes make
a fake screenshot saying Nicki Minaj is
gonna give me followers or what but the
content is not fake how's he minute
found it's fake
do you know Trump though I doubt it is
that fake yes it's fake how do I know
I'm new in I'll be doing a lot better
deals have been a lot better place I
think I would there I'm right now I do
not know truck you might have been
mentored by him sort of those
spiritually like from like a no I mean
see if you wanna go in the [ __ ] way
I can that's not the point
I didn't say two things that's what I'm
saying the things I've said and things
you can verify which I wish had made a
better attempt you could have done it
but you haven't done it so there's
things and this is making me not stuff
this cardd stuff actually happened if
somebody wanted made fake screenshot
saying I boasted about in a different
way then that's different that's not my
fault that's not my fault that's not me
doing it so you gotta see it from my
perspective too and trust me if Noah had
so much time to create and run a page
for so many months so many months it's
not it's not it's a constant offense a
constant effort to get out of paying me
the money he could have gone to coat he
did it he kept running this page of
social media creating this [ __ ] one
after another so that I let his blow and
go if today I accept it's not about the
money anymore today I accept from him
and you don't have to pay me the low and
I'm lost
here's the problem it goes back and
we're gonna have to start wrapping up
here because it goes back to the tale of
two Evan and Evan Luther is here
the problem is is as I said there are
two stories going on and if everything
else in your background everything else
in your background checks out you really
did make publish your first app when you
were 13 years old if you really did you
know create 30 out by the time you're 15
I could much easier believe like oh yeah
just sub one guy does it like I think
what you say there okay let me fit let
me I mean I wouldn't you my perspective
for this let me put my perspective to
this right okay there's two Evans I
agree in the media this media is
manufactured right but there's two Evans
in the media floating around one is what
I did what I said there is one glitch
the media has said what the media's
thing and this twelve not created by me
and then there's in the middle of this
go I know are coming in saying stuff
about me so Rob missings no no you're
controlling let me let me simply let me
let me come let me complete let me
complete I mean there's stuff there's a
lot of stuff which is up to you what you
want to believe and there's a lot of
stuff which up to you which you want to
believe right
this deuce two different kind of stuff
you can decide what you want to believe
in to me at this point it's not
affecting me and I can't be putting an
effort in time to separate or fix that
image because I didn't create it the me
it served the media I was a doing for
the media no okay listen my TV show the
rich kids of Instagram TV show I did
they made a lot of money from it they
put it out everywhere it was TRP right
it did it in 20 Airlines they made a lot
of money from it a lot of money 20 plus
airlines hey they might have put that
show for the media I was a tool same
thing happened with Google I sure may be
the example where they use me and
because of that I had a benefits in my
life I was I was a tool used by the
media I benefit and today I have
problems where the media is not going
there to mentor to me what I don't have
I don't have the control of the media I
can't control it what I can remove stuff
that's there but it doesn't affect me
today people who want to work with me
want to do business with me they have
the decision it's their control they can
decide what they want to do do your
research
I'm very good I mean a very good place
but a lot of a lot of the press about
you is basically manufactured and then
the press but it doesn't seem to be
manufactured does seem to have some
merit to it and so it's like what I
don't know but where's the minute I
think if you owned up to like for
example lying about the Steve Jobs call
it would be much I didn't sign about
that you're young can I have not wanted
to make I'm not like a name Maathai okay
okay listen Forbes all these people
they're not you can buy our continent
for I'm not deny that you can buy I
write for myself right I write an
article to pay for it yeah but you can't
because the folks will not make you a
member of the folks Technology Council
until they vet your company has had the
success to be a member of the Council
and they watch you I visited a lot of
Forbes
no listen listen okay it's one examiner
so you're telling me this random kid is
worth have more he's a better journalist
than the media companies I've been out
there I'm not denying you can find them
well random kid are you talking about
this is my this is no I don't know these
are the stuff that you're talking about
in the media right the stuff that you're
saying things that are
factually incorrect and provably wrong
that I didn't sense that that's
something that was misinformation
there's misinformation that's what I'm
coming to see the point is I can't clean
the media today it's not possible
that misinformation will be you say on
your Instagram the rich people think
differently than the average person and
my former mentor Steve Jobs was no
exception when you put that on your page
that's you control that euro narrative
and line cuz you were never that's what
I'm I told you my narrative when we
started this call and that we'd agree to
disagree on how we looked at it is the
recording of you saying that you were
not mentored by Steve Jobs and that you
never said that you quote never said
that
how do you say on a call I never said
that I was mentored by Steve Jobs I
didn't also came on record saying oh
yeah you're forgetting the point like I
said before on your call you know you're
not done the same I think I mean so many
places doing so many deals where I may
have said something with a caption
you've got to hold me for a caption the
truth is I did a call with him I built
some of the best apps for his app store
at the age of 15 they were top three
apps the number one highest honor in the
categories and they had tons in terms of
users that's the truth now if there's
stuff around that go to your research
no want to work with me that's your
choice the people who work with me
they're very happy to I made a lot of
money the people who are working with me
there's a lot of people made a lot of
money and the people who didn't make
money because they're frogs not my fault
why do you think Steve Jobs ecology just
reflecting I just I just told you
because he wanted feedback and absolute
it was a very normal call for somebody
at that time to make but the only the
AppStore was it knew though there were
hundreds of thousands but it was
absolute that already existed but it
does not how many of those apps for
attribution my apps were featured by
Apple new and noteworthy
not once not twice more than three times
do you know Steve Jobs was almost on his
deathbed when you published your first
app right buddy okay if you if you if
your goal here is to dig deep fertilize
that story there's no way to prove that
you can't put any proof up that's gonna
say it's not they're a couple and proof
of it just doesn't make sense
this guy who died this guy
died literally a year after you don't
need a lot of things that don't make
sense to you it doesn't make sense to me
why the protests are happening in the
u.s. it's police brutality in India
people get beaten up so there's more
people in India than the u.s. things
that don't make sense to you not all
things when it make sense it's a
different thing so please let's not
think you're Steve Jobs right I don't
want to argue about this because you
can't prove it you now you're thinking
for Steve Jobs you're thinking what he
would have done as if it's you know but
yours truly is provably false anybody
let's see I told you before on your
email yesterday when you restart I can't
prove the Steve Jobs call but I did
prove to you Google which is equally
equally successful company the country
heads coming up on stage and using me
and asking if my talking about my life
you want to believe that look it listen
listen let me finish now you just want
to believe your viewers want to believe
that they can believe the country out of
Google India or they can believe anybody
else they want to believe
that's up to them there's example this
stuff that can be proven the stuff can
use in the past which can be proven
that's not argue about what can it what
cannot be you we're not arguing we're
just talking about where you've lied and
I wish you would just come up and say
you lie I'd be okay
no but that's where I kind of get in lie
about the corner you think I have we
agree a titli agree to disagree agree
like gentleman in the green of the
stories I'm leaning on the the one side
because you can't you have the you have
the right to your opinion you're on the
right to your opinion you keep that I
keep mine we talked about what can be
proven and that's it if there are people
saying I lied about Steve Jobs let them
go and say it it's fine to me it's not
affecting me today because I can't
control what people say if some people
want to go say something they will say I
can't control that the missing from
howdy
go watch the Netflix documentary the
great hack how do you think Donald Trump
is president media many places people
say in sales so much in the media it's
not true but the Donald hoppers
president he basically when you plated
people the documentary is very
eye-opening for people to see how they
manipulated in the media it's it's a
great way to understand that but fee I
can't prove the call I proven what I can
prove it's in front of you the readers
have that I think this III live a
calling
four minutes I have to end this the peep
your your audience has a decision they
can make what they decide is true or not
they have the facts you are the facts
you if you want you can post everything
or you decided to pick and choose and
post what you wanted why don't you post
all the details that sent you or proof
obviously out of respect to the people
blurring out the numbers but they can
see it then they will decide who they
want to believe it's very true
everybody has a decision to decide what
they want to believe they have the
ability to do the research go into the
details of what they want to believe
they have the ability to do that
research if they really want to do it
most people who do big boost people who
are buying myth people who are dealing
with mineral deals they're not signing a
contract be it based on media my friend
they're going into the details of what
happened hey hey hey I really don't mean
to cut you off but we're going on too
long can I just ask you how much money
did you get from your father when you
started and do you consider him the
reason that you're successful I will end
this in a way that I didn't get any
money from him I didn't need any money
at the beginning like I said I didn't I
I didn't need any money because I had
those Absalon myself and I sold my first
set myself but I use compete my father
when my father had a call center that
failed my story started one of his
failures it was computers lying around
and that's how I started I didn't need
any money from him
to go and do something let's look at
this way there's two billion people in
the world at least who started off
worser than me at least two billion
worse than me but there's at least a
billion people including yourself who
started off with better surroundings in
a better place when I was born my father
had not even excited not even a bad
second not even a car when I was ten
years old my father bought his first
motorcycle before that he had no car no
money oh this is proven so I didn't need
money for me improving that hype yes you
can check that man you can check that
some of the things you're saying are not
proven buddy you can okay check this
check this please check this after the
call check it check it after the call
I'm thankful I am where I am because of
my father
I'm never gonna just say that I am
anywhere without him if it was not
because of him I would not but he didn't
give you any money that's the point he
didn't give me money I didn't need much
I didn't need money to build up you guys
heard him I didn't need any money
because I don't
I'm glad to get the the scoop I think I
saw on a documentary that you got a loan
from your father but maybe they were
wrong so maybe they were not there you
know there's another case of the media
getting it wrong Evan thank you okay the
documentaries they have got so much
stuff wrong is that they're come and
filmed a filmed me in my offices and cut
intercept stuff to make TRP he's know
about documentaries for biggest
television networks and they change the
stuff to make itself they made it look
like I'm a playboy like the first
documentary I did but they made me look
like a playboy that I'm not working that
I didn't have any success so did because
I served them I'm not denying it I
enjoyed all of my success actually I
have one documentary I thought of one
more question yeah fair enough I have
one more question bro I one minute I got
a dollar sign checks while drunk on the
super clubs hundred percent I've made
some of the best investments in my club
when you go to a nightclub like me and
get a table for 10 grand the guy next to
you is also getting a table that can run
and the guy on the other side but do you
sell your drugs do you say in virtual
contracts Wow
yeah my rap can contract yes I've signed
contracts with people in the crux and
those investments have gone on there we
come really successful good for you man
I've gotten to become really successful
well this is true hey that's for me
thanks thanks so much you have to
remember the guy in the club who's
spending 10k is not coming good job I
love you okay listen thanks for thanks
for coming on the show I hope people
have learned a lot they you know they
can go do their own research find what's
true what is it hopefully we got some of
it out today
Evan thanks for coming on get in the hot
seat you know I'm sure appreciate
appreciate you coming out and cook come
back see you had the courage to speak up
and hopefully people who watch this they
make their own decision as we go from
there I wish everyone the best and thank
you for your time mate have a good day
All Right see ya take care